[Music]
if you're looking to sell your house
right now there's a lot to think about
it's crazy out there in the real estate
world
and people are buying houses prices are
not going down
we are seeing some individual markets
that are suffering from individual
maladies for instance uh some of the
markets in houston around the energy and
the oil problems that biden has caused
the energy world we're seeing some of
those prices go down but overall the
american real estate economy is going up
because there continues to be a shortage
of housing as compared to the demand
if you're selling a house though you are
going to see with this bear market with
these increasing interest rates with us
heading into a recession you are going
to see a more normalized selling process
in most of my 40 years of fooling with
real estate i've seen about a 90-day
period of time to sell a house
i've never seen anything like the last
little bit where you would put a house
on the market and 82 people would make
an offer in seven hours
okay
that is not normal for those of you that
have been living in that world it's not
a normal world and so that world
hopefully is gone it's not healthy it's
not good for the market it's crazy it's
weird so if you're gonna sell a house
you need a good real estate agent now to
walk you through the process and to work
with the buyers that are in the market
and there are still buyers in the market
to uh get them into the house it's it's
not amateur hour out there right yeah
let me ask you a question regarding this
because this is this is wise uh to to
unpack for folks is so we are gonna see
now moving back to normalcy is what i'm
hearing you say on the amount of time to
sell but it doesn't mean that you need
to panic and lower your price just
because it's gonna take longer and
that's why we want you with a pro who
can go hey relax yeah you didn't sell it
in five days doesn't mean you need to
drop it yeah i mean i i talked to a guy
on the air yesterday he's had the house
on the market for two weeks and then got
an offer and he's panicking aha yeah
because everybody's like oh god because
we're
used to being a seller right that you're
putting a house on the market is
actually an auction
and that's that's not happening anymore
that's not going to happen in a six
percent interest rate environment
um and in the middle of a recession and
a lot of companies are laying off and so
uh
and you know it's just not gonna happen
but do we sell houses in that in that
kind of a market we have always
as a matter of fact that is a normal
market to sell houses in i've sold
houses in recession
and my whole life you know and as a real
estate person years past
um and we sold them in 1982 in a 17
interest rate wow environment and people
were buying houses not as many
as buy it three
but it's not you know and so yeah if
you're gonna put your house on the
market you need to get a really good
agent and if you're gonna buy a house
you need to get a really good agent it's
a good time to do both
and uh there's a lot of people panicking
and freaking out there's a lot of fear
out there yeah um are you hearing people
say is it dumb dave to pay six percent
when six percent is if you look at
historical rates it's not like a crazy
rate oh you're talking about the
interest rate yeah like historically
it's not here's the thing get the house
right
if rates go down refinance there you go
okay i like it i mean but you know
you're not the house is not going to go
down
and so oh yeah house prices are going to
crash ramsay you don't know what you're
talking about
honey
i have this thing called perspective
i've got a long view
and the let me tell you hope
comes from having long ball yeah
where you going to freak out mode and
your and your brain starts melting and
running out your ears is because you're
thinking short that's right and it you
know and i understand even intelligent
people become afraid and they lose their
intelligence when they become afraid
but um you're not looking at facts
you're not looking at data and you're
just freaking out because a lot of
people that are very very bright this is
their first this is their first downturn
that's right i mean 2008 was the last
one i think about a lot of young people
have never even seen a market with six
percent interest rate i don't even know
what it's like you know we never even
heard the word recession right
um or never um
never seen a slow real estate market a
medium real estate market it's always
been quite hot
because the last time listen 2007 we had
2.4
million new housing starts wow this year
we'll have 1.4
yeah we have a shortage of housing big
time and supply is just not there so
that's there's there's more buyers
chasing fewer sellers still that's
correct but just not at the auction
level i saw on the news today the ceo of
caldwell bankers said that if there were
five to six million new homes built
right now that would get us at what he
would say a normal level of supply
exactly exactly so when there's that
much shortage
it's impossible right to deduce
in a logical mind that has a long track
record and is looking at data and is not
working on feelings that the housing
market's going to crash hey the guy's
right there's a 5 million shortfall of
housing units the number of houses on
the market the last three years is 50 of
the number of houses on the market in
2007 nine right
fifty percent that's right
so here that you know just calm down
they get you a real estate agent though
go to ramseysolutions.com click on elp
and get get an agent to help you sell it
that knows what they're doing and here's
an idea
maybe an agent that has sold a bunch of
houses but maybe even an agent that has
been in the market a while
so they have perspective
because let me tell you
almost all fear
comes from no perspective here's what i
was thinking about you're driving down
the interstate today in nashville it's
like 94 freaking degrees right it's
hotter than snot out there
and it's it's also we got our little
humidity thing going so you can cut it
with a knife and put a block of humidity
in the back of the car it's unbelievable
right so you're driving down the
interstate tire blows
you're changing your tire
sweating like a pig oh yeah
and there's 18 wheelers blowing by you
about to kill you the whole time yeah
that's right thankful for the breeze
this is what's known as fear yeah this
is a bad day
horrible
my heart rate is up i have a john de
loni call coming into his show
for my mental illness that is developing
while i'm changing the tire here on the
side of the road i'm being traumatized
right this is real all the things i mean
can you think about how pissed off
angst-filled anxiety-filled fear-based
you would be in the middle of that
you're physically threatened you're hot
it's horrible you bust your knuckles on
the stupid jack yeah you know the whole
thing right
in 10 years
do you even remember that no
so did it really change your life
it's not a great point not unless you
get hit by 18 wheeler other than that it
didn't change your life right
i mean in 10 years did it really change
your life no it was a really really
scary
anxiety filled moment in time but when
you pan back
10 years
you don't even remember it that's right
you don't even remember it you have to
think hard about what happened there and
even then it's almost a chuckle
you remember that time oh that's what it
is for me because of the futility that
would happen on the side of the road you
didn't even mention that well yeah i
mean me trying to change a tire would
probably be a great clip on youtube just
because of the sheer inept we could get
a lot of hits on the camera but because
of ineptitude yeah it'd be a lot look at
this a lot of views but
now the point is think about all the bad
things in your life even something like
a cancer scare yeah i had a friend had a
cancer scare this year
and uh they came in and told him and
then they came back and go oh we missed
it
it's not there you know oh well that's
why they call it practicing medicine
so piss me off right but anyway you know
so but i mean but for about two three
weeks there we were all holding our
breath praying with this guy man
and it was everything because it was
front and center because fear is in the
moment hope is in the long ball yeah
yeah that's right you don't find hope in
the moment very often most of the time
your hope comes in the long ball yeah
perspective long-term perspective and if
you'll back up a little bit from this
and look at actual trends and data over
20 or 50 years in housing and interest
rates you cannot be so afraid i know
some of you are afraid and some of you
get real intellectual about your fear
but that doesn't make it not fear and it
doesn't make it right you're just wrong
the data is real clear on this we're
gonna do some more stuff on this we're
getting ready to announce that live
stream we're gonna do a big deal on the
real estate market and unpack some of
the things like that for
our audience to show you exactly what's
going on with this real estate market in
detail
with charts and graphs and stuff
yeah we'll let you know about that a
little bit later this is the ramsey show